rhaegar targaryen lay dead on the banks
of the trident
his royal army shattered and in retreat
the days of the dragon kings were
clearly numbered
until that moment it would have been
foolish to commit casterly rock to
either the crown
or the rebellion what would our family
have to gain in supporting a raving
madman
or in entering a crusade to put robert
baratheon on the iron throne
but chaos benefits no one
it was time for house lannister to do
what it could to ensure a return of
peace and prosperity to the land
i tywin lannister brought ten thousand
lannister troops to the gates of king's
landing
in order to bring the bloodshed to a
quick and decisive conclusion
king aerys had been sending ravens for
months
begging for my support to end the
uprising
in a way his pleas had been answered
as i had suspected ares opened the city
gates and welcomed
my men our plan was clear
crush aries remaining bannermen and
remove
the remnants of the royal family as
quickly and efficiently as possible
any alternative meant years of further
war
and a fragmented seven kingdoms
our means were bloody but the results
speak for themselves
as for aries it is true he met his fate
at the hands of my son
had kept jamie close during the
rebellion thinking himself clever
in keeping my son as a hostage should i
decide to pledge support to the rebel
cause this proved to be his greatest
mistake
for when the time came jaime did his
duty as a lannister
and drove his sword into the mad king's
back
with that robert baratheon's crown was
secured
the new king recognized our role in his
ascension to the throne
just as he recognized how useful the
might and riches of casterly rock would
be
if he wanted to keep it
to that end i offered my daughter cersei
as his queen
had aries not spurned this same offer
years earlier
perhaps things would have worked out
differently
with robert and cersei crowned as king
and queen of the seven kingdoms
it was a new day the dragon was
vanquished
and the seven kingdoms would thereafter
belong to the stag
and the lion for our rebellion to
succeed
king's landing had to be taken
forcefully
no one was foolish enough to believe
that aerys was going to hand his crown
over peacefully
the mad king's reign needed to end
what tywin lannister's forces did was
unfortunate but it was necessary to
secure the iron throne
and bring peace and justice to the seven
kingdoms
my glorious victory at the trident left
me wounded
but i sent my personal maester to attend
to sir barristan selmy instead his
wounds were more severe
even though sir barristan was a member
of eris's king's guard and fought on the
opposing side
that man's bravery and loyalty was
something to behold
but this meant my wounds would take
longer to heal and i couldn't ride to
king's landing myself
i sent the one man i trusted over anyone
else in this world
ned stark in my place
had i been able to ride perhaps i could
have reached king's landing sooner and
prevented
some of the violence that occurred when
the lannisters entered the city
still what lord tywin did was for the
greater good
even what happened to princess elia and
her children
babies oh no theirs was the same
cursed blood that flowed within the mad
king's veins
they were dragon spawn and couldn't be
allowed to survive
what would they grow to be loyal
subjects
ned with his damn northern honor
he and i had our first major fight over
the deaths of the targaryen
children ned called it murder
murder it was war
it was war
lord stark demanded that the lannisters
be held responsible for their crimes was
it a crime to put an end to a family of
lunatics born of incest
i wouldn't and still won't blame tywin
instead i sent ned stark south to finish
off the remaining targaryen loyalists
it was only lyanna stark's death that
reconciled us
ned had lost his sister i had lost my
betrothed
and beloved we shared that sad
bond together ned and i
through it our friendship was made
strong again
the battle of the trident may have been
an important victory for the usurper
but it was the treachery and barbarism
of tywin lannister that sealed the fate
of the targaryen dynasty
my father king aerys had ever been a
friend to the lions of the rock
ares graciously brought tywin to court
making him the youngest hand of the king
in history he gave him power
he gave him respect he made it possible
for tywin to restore
house lannister to glory ares and tywin
governed
side by side for 20 prosperous years
still when the usurper called his
banners in rebellion
tywin lannister ignored his king's pleas
for help
and stayed hauled up in his strongholds
of casterly rock
in time my brother prince rhaegar was
dead
the realm was in turmoil and the
usurper's forces were said to be riding
for king's landing
what a glorious sight it must have been
when a force of
ten thousand lannister men showed up at
the gate of the capital
with lord tywin at their head pledging
support to his beleaguered king
ares opened the gates for his old friend
instead lannister and his men proceeded
to plunder and destroy the city that he
had called home for decades
as the capital was ravaged and its
people terrorized
jaime lannister son of lord tywin proved
every bit as treacherous he killed my
father
the king at the foot of the iron throne
the lannisters entered the red keep and
tywin ordered the deaths of the rest of
the royal family
it is said princess rainis was found
cowering under her father's bed
and put to the sword she was only a
child
as for rhaegar's widow elia she was
forced to watch as lannister thugs
dashed her baby son's head against a
wall
before being murdered herself
as i was the heir to my father's throne
i had been spirited away to dragonstone
with my mother queen raylor who was with
child
as a raging summer storm batted the
island fortress and destroyed the
targaryen fleet as it layed anchor
my sister daenerys was born
my mother the queen died giving birth
robert baratheon's victory at the
trident was a turning point in the war
for the iron throne
while it was clear the gods were smiling
on the rebel forces
aerys targaryen still held the red keep
at king's landing
as robert was wounded and unable to ride
it was up to eddard stark to make for
the capital
and force the mad king to give up the
throne
lord stark reached the city gates to
find that tywin lannister
lord of casterly rock had already sacked
the city in robert's main
house lannister had remained neutral up
to this point
ignoring requests for help from both the
crown and the rebels
now that robert's eventual victory was
assured
it seemed lord tywin had finally chosen
the side lord eddard was horrified by
what he saw when he entered the city
homes looted and burned scores of
innocent citizens killed
disgusted he led his force up visenya's
hill to the red keep
upon entering the throne room he found
king aerys lying in a pool of blood
dead by the hand of his own sworn king's
guard
jaime lannister who sat brazenly upon
the throne
demanding to know the whereabouts of
queen raylor
lord eddard was informed the queen and
her son viserys
had been spirited away to dragonstone
before the lannisters arrived
but other members of the royal family
were not as fortunate
elia martel of dorne who was the wife of
prince rhaegar
had been murdered by sir krieg or
clegane
on lord tywin's orders sir griego and
his man had also butchered rhaegar's
young children
when robert was well enough to reach the
capital lord eddard demanded the
lannisters answer for their heinous
crimes
robert refused and sent him south to
relieve the baratheon stronghold of
storm's end
which was still under siege by forces
loyal to the crown
whatever words passed between the two
old friends and heard only to them
but lord eddard is said to have left
king's landing in anger
later when robert was crowned he
appointed john aaron as hand of the king
lord aaron's first order of business was
to broker a truce with the martells of
dawn
who were outraged by the brutal murder
of princess elia and her children
following the death of lyon stark who
had been betrothed to robert
house's baratheon and lannister were
joined in marriage
when the new king took tywin lannister's
eldest daughter cersei as his queen
as for eddard stark he returned to his
stronghold of winterfell
forever haunted by his sister's death
and the shameful way that robert had
secured his throne